the bitcoin futures etf got approved a
couple of weeks ago it went out into the
market and it has received the first one
over a billion dollars of capital
inflows the second one went out it's
also received hundreds of millions of
dollars of capital inflows but everyone
is still asking why the hell is there
not a bitcoin spot etf the bitcoin
futures etf gives people some exposure
to bitcoin but it's through futures it
is not through actually buying the asset
itself if we're to look at something
like grayscale's bitcoin trust gbtc it
is more closely tracking the price of
bitcoin than the futures products have
so far so everyone wants to know when do
we get the bitcoin spot etf grayscale
with that gbtc product that has tens of
billions of dollars of assets already in
it but does not have a redemption
function it is a trading it's a trust
that trades publicly but it is not the
etf structure they're trying to convert
their trust into an etf but everyone
wants to know who's going to be the
first and so van eck recently had a spot
etf that they had filed for the the
bitcoin spot etf ended up getting denied
last week that spot application from van
neck had a lot of the exact same
concerns that they've had with previous
bitcoin spot etf applications so van
neck what did they do they decided
they're gonna launch a bitcoin futures
etf it'll debut on the chicago-based
exchange the cboe sometime at the end of
this week or early next week the vanek
futures etf has been delayed since the
approval they got approval for the
futures etf in late october it was
supposed to launch october 25th but the
company officials had declined to
comment since then on why the new fund
had not launched yet so they're still
trying to figure out what's going on
there other future other futures etfs as
i mentioned have already been a success
in october the pro shares bitcoin etf
has gathered more than one billion
dollars in investor assets it's the
fastest etf ever to hit that milestone
and the valkyrie investments futures etf
started trading at the end of the same
week and also has gotten lots of
traction we have of course the spot
bitcoin etf application watch underway
who's going to be the first to get that
approval what investors uh want to see
or i'm sorry uh is that they want the
spot etf because they want to get direct
exposure they want to get better price
kind of alignment with the actual asset
rather than the futures but the
regulators are worried they want to know
that investors will be safe they want to
make sure that there's no manipulation
in the market so we've got to continue
to wait for that to occur we have this
quote here from the sec they said the
commission is consistently required that
the listing exchange have a
comprehensive surveillance sharing
agreement with a regulated market of
significant size related to bitcoin or
demonstrate that other means to prevent
fraudulent and manipulative acts and
practices are sufficient the listing
exchange has not met that requirement
and so there's a whole bunch of
different things that you can read into
this but one of the reasons why the
bitcoin spot etf has not been approved
yet is because many of the exchanges
that trade bitcoin spot do not actually
meet the requirements from the sec in
terms of the surveillance capabilities
what that means is they are not
overseeing the actual assets and the and
the players the way that the ssc wants
them to so we basically have a showdown
or a standoff and they're just going to
stand there and the exchanges are going
to keep trading they're going to keep
booking all this revenue for any
individual investor that wants to go on
to a crypto native exchange and they
want to buy bitcoin they can do that
they can go and get that exposure to the
asset but anybody who wants to buy it
via an etf structure they are still not
able to do it in a spot nature they are
simply looking for some sort of futures
based exposure and so ultimately if we
saw the future etfs come into the market
and get over one billion dollars worth
of assets in a very short period of time
actually the fastest ever my guess is
that a spot etf would absolutely be
explosive you could see something where
literally in the first week a bitcoin
spot etf could go from zero to like five
billion dollars in assets and it would
be something that would be absolutely
breathtaking so do we worry at all about
the spot etf uh getting uh denied uh the
application from van neck last week or
was this this was expected i think it
was expected yeah i saw uh uh it was one
of the two bloomberg etf guys that we
had on here forget which one uh but one
of them james or eric that's their name
no i know the two of them i think it was
aaron but i don't remember uh i think it
was eric but he basically put up what
the odds were and there was like 24 nfl
teams that had a higher odds to win the
super bowl right so just on a scale of
like how likely yeah those errors yeah
so eric put it up and uh just from a
likelihood that it was to get approved
the odds were a very long shot so no one
was really expecting this i think it
will happen eventually but i think
people are going to grow impatient after
a while right like what are you really
protecting people from at this point
they have the ability to go buy the spot
option in markets directly right now all
you're doing is you're you're not
allowing them to have uh the price
appreciation or see the price
appreciation that we've seen over the
last eight to 10 to 12 years so i think
uh when you start to think about what
are they protecting investors from
people are going to start to complain
but i don't think that uh this was much
of a surprise i think it's more will be
a surprise if it doesn't happen within
the next 12 to 24 months john what do
you think
uh i was not so
surprised that the vanek spot etf did
not get approved their futures etf
starts training tomorrow look
institutions are starting to fall behind
in my mind of not being able to get
access to some of this stuff due to
their compliance and the regulations and
all the risks that they have going on um
that they have to abide by but look when
they approve if and when they approve
the sec approves a spot etf they need to
approve a bunch at the same time
otherwise one person will have an unfair
advantage i believe in um just getting
all that capital